كليوباترا هل كانت سمراء ام بيضاء هل كانت
بملامح افريقيه وشعر مجعد كما صورتها منصه
نتفليكس ام بما لامح يونانيه وبشره بيضاء
كما صورت لنا في الافلام التاريخيه الجدل
على لون وملامح كليوباترا ما زال مستمرا
بعدما ظهرت ممثله سبرا في الاعلان
الترويجي لفيلم وثائقي عن حياه الملكه
الفرعونيه والمقرر عرضه في العاشر من مايو
الجاري على نتفليكس مصر رده رسميا واعتبرت
ان المنصه تقوم بتزييف التاريخ ونشرت ادله
من تماثيل ونقوش من العملات المعدنيه
الكليوباترا وظهرت فيها الملكه بملامح
يونانيه الفيلم اثار تساؤلات عن متى تاثير
حركه المركزيه الافريقيه التي تنشر فكره
ان جميع الحضارات ومنها الحضاره المصريه
كانت تضم ذوي البشره السمراء لكن تمت سرقه
ارثهم من الاوروبيين والغربيين حسب زعمهم